Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur 41. Ausgabe dieser Sendereihe. Heute hat mich der Weg mal ganz, ganz, ganz weit weg geführt von den Orten, an denen ich bisher berichtet habe. Ich befinde mich in Italien, in der Nähe von Rom, genauer in der Nähe von Frascati, denn dort sitzt die ESA mit ihrer Niederlassung unter der Bezeichnung ESRIN, bekannt, ein Zentrum für Erdbeobachtung, aber nicht nur. Und das Thema, was mich hierher geführt hat, ist ein Satellit, der vor einiger Zeit plötzlich, aber nicht ganz unerwartet sein Leben ausgehaucht hat, der aber in seiner Zeit sehr erfolgreich gearbeitet hat. Genauer handelt es sich dabei um Envisat. Und um darüber zu reden, begrüße ich Michael Rast. Hallo Michael, willkommen bei Raumzeit.
Hallo Tim, freut mich, hier zu sein.
Ja, du bist hier am S-Rennen, gibt es auch immer so tolle Tite. Head of Science, Strategy, Coordination and Planning Office. Wow, was heißt das konkret? Was ist deine Aufgabe hier?
Das heißt konkret, dass mein Team und ich uns damit beschäftigen, wie die Zukunft aussieht. Wir versuchen für unseren Direktor und für die ESA insgesamt, neue Strategien zu entwickeln, die uns den Weg ebnen wollen in die Zukunft. Wo gehen wir hin? Wie sehen die Anforderungen morgen aus an Erdbeobachtungssatelliten? Was sind die aktuellen Themen? Sind es Naturkatastrophen? Ist es der Klimawandel? Sind es Themen wie Wasserknappheit, Umweltschäden, Luftverschmutzung, Ozondiplischen? Du merkst schon, ich hab jetzt Themen aufgegriffen, die in den letzten Jahren durch die Presse gegangen sind, als Gegenstände für Satellitenuntersuchungen. Wir gucken in die Zukunft, was sind die Themen von morgen? Was sind die Anforderungen an die nächste Generation von Satelliten? Das ist etwas umständlich beschrieben in meinem langen Berufstitel, aber im Grunde genommen, das ist, was wir machen hier.
Und Esrin selber, hab ich das richtig beschrieben, dass das hier eigentlich ein Zentrum für Erdbeobachtung ist?
Das hast du richtig beschrieben. Esrin ist eins der ESA-Zentren. Und es ist speziell das, in dem die Erdbeobachtung ihren Hauptsitz hat, Erdbeobachtungszentrum auch genannt wird. Aber, hast du auch richtig gesagt, wir machen hier andere Sachen. Wir betreuen auch die Entwicklung der neuen Vega-Rakete, der, wie wir sagen, Launcher, der im Frühjahr, diesen Jahres, im Februar seinen ersten erfolgreichen Maiden Flight oder Erstflug gehabt hat. Sind wir alle sehr stolz drauf. Und dann haben wir natürlich noch...
Also die Vega, die jetzt die dritte Rakete ist und die zweite brandneue, die von Kuru aus startet und die ja im Wesentlichen eine italienische Entwicklung ist.
Das ist richtig. Ja, und die ist also auch hier beheimatet bei der S-Renn. Und dann haben wir noch einen ganz starken Information Technology Hauch haben wir hier auch noch. Aber Erdbeobachtung ist das dominante Thema.
Ja, Erdbeobachtung ist auch hier für diese Ausgabe das dominante Thema. Es geht um Envisat. Envisat ist ja eigentlich ein relativ bekannter Satellit. Das ist zumindest meine Wahrnehmung. Es fliegt ja so einiges Metall um die Erde herum. Aber nicht jedes Projekt hat so eine gewisse Bekanntheit. Erfahrene ich, ob du diese Meinung so teilen würdest, wenn man ein bisschen schwierig wahrscheinlich so aus dem Zentrum heraus so eine Beobachtung zu machen?
Naja, nein, die Beobachtung, die kann ich ohne weiteres teilen. Und ich bin da ein bisschen vorbelastet, weil ich bin schon sehr lang bei der ESA und ich stand eigentlich an der Wiege von Envisat damals. Und es gibt ja so nette Sprüche, es ist nicht zu glauben, was man erreichen kann, wenn man nicht weiß, was unmöglich ist. Und das ist so im Retrospect heute, was damals mit Envisat passiert ist. Weil wir haben neben der Tüchtigkeit und den Visionen auch unheimlich viel Glück gehabt, dass das funktioniert hat. Und so ein großer Satellit ist noch nie da gewesen und ist auch später nicht mehr realisiert worden. Auch von der NASA nicht und auch, wie hinterher die Qualität der Beobachtungen gezeigt hat. Das war schon Leading Edge. Und drum ist er auch bekannt und berühmt geworden, der Envisat. Er ist auch, wir haben mal die Schlagzeilen gesammelt. Ich kann es dir jetzt gar nicht sagen, wie viele das waren. Aber wir haben mit Envisat sehr oft die Titelseiten von nicht nur wissenschaftlichen Journalen, sondern auch von Tageszeitungen erreicht. Und zwar in allen europäischen Ländern.
Ja, wie es dazu im Einzelnen kam, können wir noch mal drauf eingehen. Ich würde jetzt allerdings erst mal so ein bisschen zurückspulen. Zunächst einmal vielleicht kannst du noch mal so deinen eigenen, persönlichen Werdegang noch mal darlegen, wie der hier überhaupt bei der ESA geendet ist.
Ja, also der Werdegang ist Gott sei Dank im Augenblick noch nicht beendet. Und ich hoffe, es geht noch ein bisschen weiter für mich hier bei der ESA. Ich habe Geologie studiert an der Ludwig-Maximilians-Universität in München und mich schon in den ersten anderthalb Jahren meines Studiums für die Fernerkundung interessiert. Das war damals war München eigentlich eins der ersten Uni-Institute, die Fotogrammetrie und Fernerkundung überhaupt gemacht haben in Deutschland. Und das war also ein richtiges Pionierinstitut. Und ich habe da als junger Hiwi-Hilfsassistent angefangen als Student und war derart von der Raumfahrt, der Thematik und vor allem dem Planeten Erde fasziniert, dass ich gesagt habe, das will ich weitermachen.
Vor welchem Jahr sprechen wir jetzt?
Wir sprechen jetzt vom Jahr 79. Und habe dann diese Hilfsjobs weiterbekommen und habe dann im Diplom, im Hauptdiplom, nicht nur Diplomprüfung, sondern also auch meine Diplomarbeit zum Teil über Fernerkundung, Geologie in der Fernerkundung geschrieben und habe mich dann nach Abschluss des Studiums auf ein sogenanntes Young Graduate Trainee Fellowship beworben. Dieses Fellowship Trainee Scheme gibt es heute noch bei der ESA und ist ein attraktiver Punkt für viele junge Abiturienten oder Nachabiturienten oder Hochschulabgänger, die sich bei uns dann bewerben. Und einige dieser jungen Leute sind halt dann auch kleben geblieben bei der ESA, eben weil es ein sehr faszinierendes und interessantes Thema ist. Ich kam Anfang 85 zur ESA als Young Graduate, ursprünglich für ein Jahr. Und wie das halt so ist, man durchläuft ein paar Verträge, wird verlängert und irgendwann nachdem ich zehn Jahre dabei war, habe ich meinen in Anführungszeichen lebenslangen Vertrag bekommen und bin, wie du dir ausrechnen kannst, seit 27 Jahren bei der ESA und habe immer noch Freude.
27 Jahre, jetzt muss ich mal ein bisschen rechnen, also 85 bist du dazugekommen. Was war denn zu dem Zeitpunkt in der Erdbeobachtung die zu bewältigende Herausforderung und was hat dann letzten Endes auch zu dem Design von Envisat geführt? Also womit hat man sich damals beschäftigt, was wollte man wissen, wo war klar, dass man irgendwie noch nichts weiß?
Esa konnte damals auf seine erste Pionierleistung zurückblicken und zwar den Mediusat, die operationellen meteorologischen Satelliten, die 36.000 Kilometer von uns entfernt, über dem Äquator und Nullten Längengrad fest verankert Europa beobachten und als erster Satellit so richtig für Europa in die Wettervorhersage eingegriffen haben. Das war eigentlich ein großes Achievement, aber das big game in town, wenn ich so ab und zu mal so einen Anglismus einfließen lassen darf, war Ea-S1, the European Remote Sensing Satellite 1. Der ging schon auf Ideen zurück, die es in der Vorläuferorganisation von ESA in der ESRO gab. Also da hat man schon in den 70er Jahren davon geträumt, nicht einen geostationären Wetter Satelliten, sondern einen Satelliten zu bauen, der die Erde über den Polen umfliegt, während sie sich darunter wegdreht und damit man eine globale Beobachtung des Planeten Erde erreicht. Die Schwerpunkte waren Oceanografie, waren Eis und dieser ERS-1, an dem wurde gearbeitet und was man auch damals wollte, nicht mit optischem Gerät, sondern man wollte mit einem aktiven Mikrowellengerät, einem Radar und zwar einem abbildenden Radar, die Amerikaner hatten das vorher schon gemacht, wollte man aber mit höherer Genauigkeit die Ozeane angucken. Weil mit diesen aktiven Radaren kann man halt durch die Wolken auch durchschauen, ist also Wetter, Sturm, Wind, Tag und Nacht unabhängig und dieser Satellit wurde damals gebaut, wurde dann 1991 gestartet und damals haben wir Satelliten anders gebaut als heute, da gab es diese sogenannte Modellpolitik, man hat also von jedem Satelliten in den verschiedenen Stufen der Entwicklung verschiedene Modelle gebaut und da waren mehrere Teile in doppelter oder dreifacher Redundanz verfügbar und weil man natürlich alles testen musste, es war alles Neuland, man hatte auch wenig Erfahrung mit der Qualifikation der einzelnen Teile, wurden mehrere Teile vom selben Modell raumflugtauglich hergestellt. Und nachdem ERS-1 1991 gestartet derart großer Erfolg war, hat man nachgesehen und festgestellt, dass man so viele doppelte Redundansteile hatte, dass die ESA zu ihren Vertretern der Mitgliedsländer zurückgegangen ist und gesagt hat, wir könnten einen ERS-2 bauen aus vorhandenen Teilen, wir hätten dann noch ein bisschen Platz sogar auf dem Satelliten, könnten vielleicht noch ein kleines Instrument dazu bauen und was ich sage war damals natürlich schon auch ein klein wenig hemmsärmlich, auch wenn alles nach ganz genauen Prozeduren damals schon ablief. Aber die Entscheidungswege waren kürzer. Unsere Delegationen haben immer mitgearbeitet bei der ESA. Es ist fantastisch, dass die Politiker der Länder, die ihre Delegierten da entsanden, uns nie, eigentlich nie Steine in den Weg gelegt haben. Dann haben wir versucht, die Mittel zur Verfügung zu stellen, es lief parallel eine Entwicklung für ein kleines Instrument, das hieß GOME, Global Ozone Monitoring Experiment. Das hat den Nerven und den Zeitgeist absolut getroffen, weil es auf das Ozonloch gezielt Beobachtungen machen sollte. Die Veränderungen und die Dynamik, der Ozonloch ist eigentlich ein falscher Ausdruck. Die Ausdünnung der Ozonschicht sollte man auch beobachten. Man hat also diesen ERS-2 zusammengebaut, hat dieses GOME, das erste Atmosphären-Chemie-Instrument von einem europäischen Satelliten da draufgesetzt und den dann 95 gestartet. Und ERS-1 hat da oben immer noch gut funktioniert. Und dann hat man halt mit zwei Satelliten gearbeitet, hat sehr viel bessere Bedeckung bekommen, hat ganz tolle Einsichten in die Ozeanografie. Die Dynamik, die Physik der Ozeane bekommen, hat tolle Sachen gemacht, hat rausgefunden, dass der kürzeste Seeweg nicht immer unbedingt der effizienteste ist. Wir konnten also signifikante Wellenhöhen beobachten, Rogue-Waves beobachten, Meeresspiegel-Schwankungen beobachten. Wir haben ganz genau vermessen die Täler und Berge der Ozeanoberfläche, weil, wie in früheren Sendungen, bei dir glaube ich schon besprochen, also unsere Ozeanoberfläche ist keineswegs flach, sondern schmiegt sich also den Tiefseegräben und den mittelatlantischen Rücken an.
Und vor allem dem Erdschwerefeld.
Verursacht durch die Anziehungskraft der Erde, durch ihr Schwerefeld. Und solche Sachen, die waren alles sehr spannend, die haben wir beobachtet. Aber wie das halt so oft ist, wenn so ein Satellit für die Ozeanografie ausgelegt ist, dann sagen die Landwissenschaftler, Moment einmal, 99,9 Prozent der Erdbevölkerung leben auf dem Land und man hat dann festgestellt, dass man mit dem gerade auch fantastische Aufnahmen über Land machen konnte. Und Tropenwälder, Abholzung der Tropenwälder, Sahelzone, Landtransformation, Hangrutschungen. Und jetzt komme ich in ein Thema rein.
War denn das für die Wissenschaftler auch eine Überraschung oder war das nur so, dass man das immer geahnt hat, aber jetzt konnte man das auch mal belegen und in einer größeren Öffentlichkeit zum Überraschtsein präsentieren?
Beides. Beides. Es gab natürlich schon vorher Radargeräte, habe es vorhin erwähnt, also von den Amerikanern gestartet. Shuttle Imaging Raider. Noch vorher gab es auf dem NIMBO-7-Satelliten den SESAT. Das waren schon aktive Mikrowellengeräte, mit denen man gewisse Untersuchungen gemacht hat. Aber SESAT hat nur 90 Tage gelebt. Die Shuttle Imaging Raider-Missions, die waren natürlich durch die Shuttle-Exkursionen sehr zeitbegrenzt, aber man hatte Daten, man wusste, dass man in trockene, lose Sandbögen, Böden eindringen kann und für die Archäologie tolle Beobachtungen machen. Man wusste, dass man Rodungen von Tropenwäldern oder Morphologieveränderungen an der Landoberfläche sehen kann. Aber was wir zum Teil über die Ozeanographie rausgekriegt haben, die Windgeschwindigkeiten, die sich aus der Beobachtung der Wellen ableiten ließ, die Meeresspiegel-Schwankungsgenauigkeiten, das haben wir uns damals nicht vorgestellt, dass wir in diese Genauigkeitsbereiche vorbringen würden. Das war für uns neu.
Was heißt, dann saßen hier alle und waren etwas überschwemmt von dem ganzen Datenmaterial, haben aber sich dran gemacht, das mal auszuwerten und kamen dann erst mal auf neue Ideen.
Auch hier wieder kein schwarz-weiß-Bild, einige haben die Bilder sofort umgesetzt, bei anderen haben sich die Bilder gestapelt in den Büros. Ich weiß, ich bin damals ab und zu, ich war damals in einer wissenschaftlichen Abteilung tätig, es war die Mission Science Division, und da bin ich natürlich zu vielen Wissenschaftlern gereist. Da haben sich dann manchmal solche, die sich immer beschwert haben, nicht genug Daten zu bekommen, die haben sich dann als solche herausgestellt, die die ungeöffneten ESA-Umschläge mit den Daten auf dem Schreibtisch gestapelt haben. Also auch da sehr nette Anekdoten, aber die Mehrzahl unserer Scientists war sehr, sehr enthusiastisch und die haben schon wirklich alle, und ich muss auch sagen, im Schulterschluss, da nach vorne gearbeitet. Und ja, die größte Entdeckung für mich eigentlich mit EAS war auch eine Technologie, die schon bekannt war und die eigentlich die Amerikaner damals entwickelt hatten, aber da ist nie was mit gemacht worden, das war die sogenannte SAR-Interferometrie. Also SAR steht für Synthetischer Arperturradar, das heißt man erzeugt mit einer kürzeren Antenne synthetisch eine längere und kriegt eine sehr, sehr gute Bodenauflösung in diesem aktiven Radarbild. Und die SAR-Interferometrie, die kann man dahingehend nutzen, dass man zwei Aufnahmepunkte zusammenbringt und aus den verschiedenen Blickwinkeln die Phasenverschiebung als Informationsquelle benutzt. Und so hat man, wie ähnlich in der optischen Stereoskopie kann man dreidimensionale Datensätze erstellen, aber mit einer derartigen Genauigkeit, dass man also Veränderungen toll erkennen kann.
Dazu hatten wir ja auch schon ein Gespräch, da muss ich gleich mal die Gelegenheit nutzen, hier querverweist zu machen, wer es noch nicht gehört hat. Raumzeit 37 hat sich ausführlich mit dem Tandem X-Projekt auseinandergesetzt, das ja die ambitionierteste Variante dieser ganzen SAAR-Beobachtungssysteme darstellt. Und wo eben auch die Vorzüge und vor allem auch die vielfältigen Ergebnismöglichkeiten dieser Beobachtungsformen da ausführlich herausgestellt werden. Kann ich sehr empfehlen, das Gespräch ist vielleicht toll. Das heißt, es war jetzt zu dem Zeitpunkt, quasi mit diesen ersten beiden Missionen, hat man eigentlich zwei Fliegen mit einer Klappe geschlagen. Erstens hat man sich selber klargemacht, was man alles so für Möglichkeiten hat. Zweitens war auch die Öffentlichkeit, zog schon so ein bisschen mit. Meteorosat, ich kann mich noch daran erinnern, 70er Jahre, da tauchten halt auf einmal diese wunderbaren Wolkenkarten in der Wettervorhersage auf, die es so vorher nicht gab. Vorher hatte man immer so, ja, hier wahrscheinlich Sonne und da noch mal ein kleines Wolkensymbol. Und auf einmal konnte man dann irgendwie schön immer sehen, wie so die Wolken über Europa zogen. Und Meteorosat wurde eingeblendet. Das war ja dann auch schon so ein, vielleicht nicht das erste, aber doch ein extrem sichtbares Signal der Präsenz der Raumfahrt und damit natürlich auch der Erdbeobachtung. Wie kam es denn dann zu Envisat?
Ja, das ist auch wieder eine Geschichte mit verschiedenen Einflussfaktoren. Es gab damals die Raumstation war im Entstehen und man hat damals ein bisschen gesagt, only the sky is the limit. Man hat also versucht, schneller, höher, weiter. Die Planung der Raumstation war derart umfassend, dass man gesagt hat, na, müssen wir für die Erdbeobachtung auch was tun. Während die Raumstation in ihrem 240 bis 300 Kilometer Orbital Range verbleibt, wollen wir noch zwei polare Plattformen, die gleichzeitig über die Pole fliegen und die Erde beobachten. Und da gab es dann auch noch nicht realisierbare Träume. Also mit polare Plattformen, diese typische Erdbeobachtungstraaktion zwischen 700 und 800 Kilometer, die immer die Pole überfliegt und damit, während die Erde sich dreht, eine globale Beobachtungsposition hat. Und da gab es dann diesen verrückten Traum, die Polar Plattformen von der Raumstation aus mit einem Service zu belegen. Das heißt, Astronauten, diesen verrückten Traum, da gab es aber nur kurze Zeit, sollten von der Raumstation aus unter Umständen Instrumente austauschen oder Treibstoff nachtanken und solche Geschichten. Da hat sich aber dann herausgestellt, dass man von der Inklination, also vom Orbit der Raumstation, ich glaube, man hätte fast eine Saturn V-Rakete da oben gebraucht, um diese Inklinationswechsel zu überwinden und um zur Polaren Plattform zu kommen. Außerdem wäre also die Strahlungsenvironment für Astronauten denkbar schädlich gewesen. Der Gedanke wurde sehr schnell verworfen und es gab dann auch natürlich Limits, was das Budget betraf. Also hat man eine der Plattformen gestrichen, aber eine ist übrig geblieben. Eine polare Plattform ist übrig geblieben und es waren sehr viele Anwendungs- und Nutzungsstudien auf dieser Plattform gemacht worden. Und man hat auch viele Erdbeobachtungs-Proposals für diese Polar Plattform bekommen. Die wurde dann später in POEM umgetauscht, Polar Observing Earth Mission. Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, wie das Akronym hieß. Es können sich da nur noch wenige erinnern, weil das ist schon ewig lang her. Und aus dieser POEM-Plattform wurde dann Envisat. Man hat verschiedene User-Konsultationen abgehalten, um aus dieser Landschaft von Vorschlägen, Missionsvorschlägen, die geeigneten Instrumente auszuwählen. Da hatten wir die besten Wissenschaftler an Bord, also auch solche, die damals wissenschaftlich Helmut Kohl beraten haben in Deutschland. Und es war schon sagenhaft. Und wir hatten dann einen ziemlich rigorosen Approach. Der war also wirklich wissenschaftlich getrieben. Wir haben uns da nicht viel reinreden lassen von irgendwelchen politischen Strömungen. Und es war wirklich die beste Wissenschaft, die da gewonnen hat. Damals hatten wir auch einen Superpartner als Hauptauftragsnehmer. Schon bei ERS-1 und ERS-2 war auch Dornier-Systeme Friedrichshafen wieder der Hauptauftragsnehmer für Envisat. Und das war ein super Partner. Und wir hatten dann für jedes Instrument wissenschaftliche Beratergruppen, sogenannte Science-Advisal Groups, erstellt. Und für jedes Instrument, das dann auf Envisat war, haben wir ein begleitendes Wissenschaftlerteam gehabt, die uns immer geführt haben, was die Anforderungen betraf. Viele der Anforderungen waren damals noch nicht so bekannt. Das heißt, man musste auch Fallstudien nebenher machen, man musste ins Labor, man hat Instrumente auf Flugzeuge geschnallt, ist dann durch die Gegend geflogen. Ein guter Partner für all diese Kampagnen. Und eigentlich unser Hauptkampagnenpartner war damals das DLR. Damals hieß es noch DFVLR, Deutsche Forschungs- und Versuchsanschalt für Luft- und Raumfahrt in Oberpfaffenhofen. Ja, und die waren genauso begeistert wie wir. Und da hat man also auch kurze Wege gefunden, um schnelle Resultate darzustellen. Und das war schon toll.
Da würde ich gerne mal drauf eingehen. Was macht denn einen guten Partner aus? Wann hebt man an zu so einer Illoge? Wann sagt man, guter Partner? Was ist wichtig in dieser Zusammenarbeit, gerade auch zwischen kommerziellen Unternehmen, wie aber auch anderen Organisationen? Was kräftigt diesen Prozess?
Es ist wie bei einem guten Kuchenrezept. Du brauchst die richtigen Ingredienzen. Eine allein reicht nicht. Ganz vorne an steht natürlich Kompetenz und Enthusiasmus. Dann ist ein gewisses Quantum an lateralem Denken und Flexibilität vonnöten, um zu sehen, was kann ich wirklich machen? Ich will nicht verhehlen, dass eine gewisse Perseveranz und Verbissenheit notwendig ist, um diese Dinge durchzuziehen. Denn wir wussten damals schon, um solche Satelliten oder solche Instrumente in die Realität umzusetzen, brauchst du zehn Jahre. Du musst also einen Weitblick haben, du musst eine Vision haben, musst aber gleichzeitig auf dem Boden der Tatsachen bleiben. Man muss natürlich auch ab und zu mal Vertrauen haben im Partner. Es gab ja Leute, die gesagt haben, das geht nie. Und die Technologie hat dann, und wir erleben das heute noch mit unseren Nachfolgen, mit unseren Explorer-Satelliten. Ich will jetzt nicht sagen jeden Tag, aber wir haben in den letzten fünf Jahren Technologien entwickeln, wo die Leute gesagt haben, das geht nie. Zum Beispiel mit unserem Gravity-Satelliten Goche, der also das schwere Feld vermisst zu einer Genauigkeit, wie es nie möglich gehalten wurde. Und so haben wir halt mehrere Technologien gehabt. Und ich kann mich erinnern, einer unserer wissenschaftlichen Berater, der hat damals zu mir gesagt, als der Satellit Envisat im Testing bei British Aerospace, damals hieß noch British Aerospace in England, er hat gesagt, ich habe mir gesehen, ihr habt mir mal angeguckt, wie viele 100 Kilometer, die da Kabel verlegt haben. Michael, das geht ja nie. Und sowas haben wir öfter gehört. Und manchmal haben die Ingenieure zu uns gesagt, ihr seid wohl verrückt, diese Anforderungen, die können wir als Industriebetrieb nicht garantieren. Und umgekehrt haben wir gesagt, das wollt ihr machen, schafft ihr denn das? Und das ist dieses Give and Take. Und da wächst man zusammen und da gibt es sehr, sehr viel auch aufreibende Momente, im Punkt, wo erreichen wir das oder es gibt Brückschläge, die man dann kompensieren muss, wo man wieder neu ansetzen muss. Aber am Ende wächst so eine Partnerschaft dann auch. Und das haben wir auch gesehen, dass wir mit gewissen Raumfahrtbetrieben, Industriebetrieben halt immer wieder das große Los gezogen haben. Und die, die irgendwie nicht ganz so weit waren wie die anderen, sind dann durch den Prozess mitgezogen worden. Und ich schaue jetzt auch an Länder, die später gekommen sind in diesen Raumfahrtkernen. Europa wie Spanien und auch skandinavische Länder, die haben Kompetenzen entwickelt, auch durch diesen Sog. Und der da, kann man ruhig sagen, auch um Envisat entstanden ist.
Ja, wie du so eingangs schon so schön sagtest, es ist gut, wenn man nicht weiß, was alles unmöglich ist. Dann kommt man da weiter. Kommen wir mal konkret auf Envisat. Du hast ja schon angedeutet, das ist ein sehr umfangreiches Projekt gewesen. Das ist der größte Satellit, der so in der Form bisher gebaut wurde. So einen Größenwahn, in Anführungsstrichen, wirkt ja auch einige Risiken, weil wenn dann irgendwas nicht funktioniert, wird ja auch alles andere gleich mit reingezogen. Und vor allem so ein riesiges Experiment, das muss ja auch erstmal in den Orbit geschossen werden. Was hat einen dazu gebracht, das so alles auf so ein riesiges Instrument draufzubringen? War es so ein strategischer Vorteil, dass man wirklich alle Beobachtungen, also zehn Instrumente sind ja drauf, alle haben einen anderen Blick auf diese Welt? Ist das sozusagen so ein wichtiger Faktor, dass sie alle von der selben Zeit, von der selben Stelle gucken oder waren das andere Argumente an der Stelle?
Da kamen verschiedene Argumente zusammen. Das erste Argument war, man hatte angefangen, die Oceanografie vom Weltraum aus so anzureißen und wollte unbedingt in diese Richtung weitermachen. Da hieß es, okay, Envisat sollte auf jeden Fall versuchen, das Sport zu führen, was mit ERS 1 und 2 begonnen wurde. Aber die Atmosphärenwissenschaftler haben natürlich durch GOME auch gesehen, dass die Atmosphärenchemie an Bedeutung gewonnen hat. Die Ozonproblematik, die Treibhausgasproblematik sollte natürlich auch Antworten bekommen. Das hieß die Lobby der Atmosphärenchemie und der Atmosphärendynamik war ganz, ganz stark. Und die haben gesagt, da brauchen wir das. Das ist extrem wichtig.
Das ist auch das Megathema der Ozeane.
Absolute zentrale Umweltprobleme. Wir wussten zwar viel über die Physik der Ozeane, aber die Biologie der Ozeane, eins der größten Carbon oder Kohlenstoff-Sinks auf unserem Planeten, waren unerforscht. Oder weitgehend unerforscht. Es gab die amerikanische CZCS, Coastal Zone Colorscan Emission, aber da war die Auflösung nicht so toll. Von der Radiometrie war es nicht so toll. Wir wollten einfach was Besseres. Und so kamen diese Argumente zusammen. Im Grunde genommen haben wir damals schon die Gefahr gesehen, alle Eier in einen Korb zu legen. Denn wenn das schief ging, dann wäre entsetzlich viel Blutschweiß und Tränen verloren gegangen. Und natürlich auch sehr viel Geld. Man war sich der Gefahr bewusst. Auf der anderen Seite wollte man die Erde auch disziplinübergreifend erforschen. Wir wollten also die Wechselwirkungen zwischen Atmosphäre, Ozean- und Landoberflächen verstehen lernen. Und das war auch die Hauptargumentation, einen Umwelt-Satelliten zu schießen, der diese Disziplin übergreifend alle Themen gleichzeitig angucken kann. Dass wenn irgendwo die Temperatur hochgeht, man ein Verständnis hat, woran das liegen könnte, oder die Polkappen, die abschmelzen, und die Ozonschicht, die sich ausdünnt.
So ein bisschen so ein Schweizer Taschenmesser im Himmel.
Ganz früh in der Envisat-Phase war klar, wenn wir mal so ein Grundverständnis haben, und ich behaupte, da fehlt immer noch einiges, aber wir haben schon sehr viel gelernt durch Envisat, dann würden wir gezielt in die Forschungsbereiche mit dedizierten Satelliten nachstoßen. Das ist genau das, was wir heute machen in unserem Rahmenprogramm. Aber das war deine Frage beantwortend, das war die unterliegende Ratio. Das war im Grunde genommen das Verständnis, aber auch die Argumentation, warum ein riesengroßer Satellit und dieses Risiko. Und dann kam halt noch das zusätzliche Risiko. Wir hatten die Kollegen von Space Science, also von der außerhalb der Erde Raumflugwissenschaft, die hatten leider Gottes ihren Cluster-Satelliten auf der neuen Ariane 5 verloren. Und man hat also da versucht, dem auf die Spur zu kommen. Man hat versucht, die Probleme zu beheben. Und auch der Start vor Envisat, nämlich der Artemis, der Data Relay Satellite, der eigentlich für Envisat damit auch hochgeschossen worden war, hat seinen Orbit nicht ganz erreicht. Und nur aufgrund dieser wunderbaren Ionen-Triebwerke ist dann nach langer, langer Zeit geschafft, auf den Orbit zu kommen. Er wurde zu früh ausgesetzt, weil Ariane halt ihre Höhe nicht erreicht hat. Also da gab es nicht nur großes Zittern wegen des Envisat-Satelliten. Wird er funktionieren, ist die Technik okay. Sondern es gab auch die Angst, schafft die Rakete das. Und die Rakete hat den Satelliten so traumhaft exakt in den Orbit eingeschossen, dass wir Treibstoff gespart haben, um den Satelliten lageregeln und länger betreiben zu können. Denn die Treibstofftanks waren die gleichen wie auf ERS und eigentlich für den großen Satelliten, für einen längeren Betrieb zu klein ausgelegt. Aber hat alles funktioniert.
Also Envisat ist in Kuru gestartet mit einer späteren Version der Ariane 5, die dann nicht explodiert ist. Und was hat das Ding gewogen? 8 Tonnen?
8,2 Tonnen. Mit ausgefahrenem Solarpaneel war der Satellit 25 Meter lang. Hat 8,2 Tonnen gewogen. Und die Spannweite bestimmt durch die große Aser-Radarantenne 10 Meter. Und damit ist er der größte, ich glaube, das Hubble Space Teleskop, das man jetzt nicht so ohne weiteres als Satelliten-Freifliegender bezeichnen kann, war, glaube ich, 15 Zentimeter länger oder so. Aber von den frei fliegenden Satelliten vom Boden aus, startend und freigesetzt, ist Envisat mit Sicherheit der größte.
Das heißt, die Annahme war, das Ding fünf Jahre lang fliegen sollte. Aber es wurde schon nach dem Start relativ klar, dass man so bestimmte Reserven, die man vielleicht einkalkuliert hat, so gar nicht anzapfen muss, sodass sich schon abgezeichnet hat, dass es vielleicht länger halten könnte?
Wir sind natürlich mit unseren Maßgaben immer sehr, sehr konservativ. Es ist auch so, wenn du dir eine Uhr oder ein elektronisches Gerät im Laden kaufst, bekommst du eine Garantie. Und je nach Garantieleistung muss natürlich der Hersteller kalkulieren. Unsere Industrie, die haben damals gesagt, drei bis fünf Jahre Lebensdauer. Und dementsprechend haben sie auch eine gewisse Garantie für das Instrumentarium übernommen. In dem Moment, wo wir eine längere Lebensdauer angestrebt oder eine längere Lebensgarantie angestrebt hätten, wäre der Satellit, der ohne dies schon viel gekostet hat, noch viel teurer geworden. Ich kann das ja ruhig erzählen. Zu damaligen Zeiten war natürlich dieser Kostenrahmen von 2,1 bis 2,2 Milliarden Euro. Das war für damalige Begriffe sehr, sehr viel Geld. In Retrospekt hat es sich gelohnt und war eine super Investition. Nicht nur die Wissenschaft hat sehr viel gelernt, sondern auch die Industrie. Es war schon eine gute Partnerschaft. Man kann auch ruhig sagen, dass es dann einige Länder gab, die im Vorfeld der Staatskalte Füße bekommen haben und gesagt haben, wir müssen den Envisat unbedingt kleiner machen. Wir müssen den diskopen, hieß das damals. Unser damaliger Generaldirektor durfte sich solchen Dingen nicht verschließen. Ich weiß noch, da gab es ein großes Meeting Ende der 90er-Jahre. Da wird auch heute nicht gerne darüber gesprochen, kann man aber ruhig sagen, gehört ja dazu. Er hat gesagt, ja, sollen wir den Envisat in ein bisschen abspecken? Nach langem Hin und Her.
Also aus finanziellen Erwägungen.
Aus finanziellen Erwägungen heraus. Nach langem Hin und Her hat man dann erwogen, wir specken ein bisschen ab. Was nehmen wir runter? Dann haben die Atmosphärenchemiker geschrien, wie noch was geht gar nicht. Den Radar, unser Flaggschiff-Instrument, kommt ja überhaupt nicht in Frage. Ja, und Meres war eigentlich das Instrument für dich, für das ich die ersten Spezifikationen geschrieben habe. 1986 schon. Also praktisch 15 Jahre bevor Envisat überhaupt gestartet wurde. Aber wir haben halt sehr früh mit diesem Ozean-Biologie-Instrument angefangen. Das war damals, hat sich das, das optische Bild in sechs Module aufgeteilt. Und dann hat man gesagt, da können wir ein bisschen dran schrauben oder dran sägen, wir nehmen einfach ein Modul ab. Und die Industrie hat natürlich geschrien, wollten das nicht machen, und sie aber dann im Endeffekt natürlich beugen müssen. Und man hat aufgrund dieses Hoheitsbeschlusses hat man ein Modul entfernt, um Geld zu sparen. Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie viel Zehnermillionen dadurch Envisat teurer geworden ist. Aber da haben wir auch wieder was Wichtiges gelernt. Wenn man so weit in der Entwicklung drin ist, dann gibt es nur das Motto Don't look back.
Dann machen Änderungen es eher noch teurer.
Genau. Und wir haben dann die Lebensdauer...
Weniger ist mehr. Reloaded.
In dem Fall war das nicht zutreffend. Wir haben durch die Lebensdauer von Envisat hindurch immer so ein klein bisschen gelitten, dass die, man nennt es Schwartbreite, also der Augen, der Blickwinkel von Meris, dann doch leider Gottes um 150 oder 180 Kilometer schmäler war, als wir es gerne gehabt hätten. Trotzdem war Meris ein brillantes Instrument und hat uns nicht nur über den Ozean, für die Ozeanbiologie, sondern auch über der Landvegetation viele neue Einsichten gewährt. Da haben wir viel gelernt.
Ja, das bringt uns eigentlich mal dazu, woraus Envisat besteht. Weil Envisat, das ist ja jetzt klar geworden, ist vor allem so eine Kombination aus mehreren Dingen. Und die einzelnen Instrumente machen das Projekt eigentlich aus. Das ist bloß alles auf diesem VW-Bus namens Envisat drauf installiert. Ich glaube, das ist in etwa die Größe, die man sich so vorstellen muss.
Nee, nee, VW-Bus ist viel, viel kleiner. Also der Korpus von dem Satelliten an sich ist 10 Meter. Da spricht man also von...
10 Meter lang.
10 Meter lang, der Korpus aber nur. Da spricht man also von zwei VW-Bussen hintereinander. Und dann quer kann man dann die Radarantenne, das sind auch wieder 10 Meter, da kannst du auch wieder zwei stellen und dann hinten das Solarpedal, das sind nochmal 10 Meter.
Das ist schon eher ein Parkplatz mit VW-Bussen.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wir sprechen da von einem kleinen VW-Bus-Stau.
Wow, ein Monster. Ein Monster. Das heißt, das kam dann alles in den Orbit, dann wird das wahrscheinlich erstmal eine längere Inbetriebnahmephase gegeben haben, bis alles entsprechend kalibriert, justiert, überprüft und getestet war. Lief denn dann alles?
Die Commissioning Phase, so heißt diese Inbetriebnahme, die wurde ausgedehnt, ich weiß es nicht mehr genau, nagel mich bitte nicht fest, ich glaube, es sollten ursprünglich drei Monate sein und es wurde dann ein halbes Jahr. Es hat nicht immer alles einwandfrei funktioniert. Wir hatten kleine Probleme mit Atmosphärenchemie, Instrument, dann hatten wir kleine Probleme hier und da, aber in großen und ganzen sind eigentlich alle Instrumente bis zum Schluss gelaufen. Ja, kann man also so sagen, grosso modo hat alles funktioniert. Es gab mal ein Kalibrationsproblem hier und es waren viele Episoden, ich will da jetzt nicht ins Detail gehen. Ich glaube, dass kurz vor Ende, ich glaube, hatten wir Probleme mit GOMOS, eins der Atmosphärenchemie-Instrumente, Global Ozone Monitoring by Solar Occultation, hieß der GOMOS, also eins der Ozone-Geräte. Dann hatten wir den MIPAS, Michelson Interferometer for Passive Atmospheric Sounding und den Skiamaki, das Scanning Absorption Spectrometer, mit dem wir auch Sachen erreicht haben, die Universität Bremen stand hinter dem Instrument. Zum Schluss ist es dann wirklich auch geschafft, CO2, also Kohlendioxid, und CH4 Methan zu kartieren. Ganz interessant, aber auch Stickstoffoxide. Diese Sachen haben alle funktioniert. Man kann also sagen, wir hatten keinen Ausfall in dem Sinn.
Gehen wir noch mal auf die einzelnen Sensoren ein, weil ich glaube, das ist ganz interessant, mal zu schauen, was da jetzt eigentlich drauf war und was für ein Blick damit jetzt überhaupt erst eröffnet wurde.
Womit fängt man denn dann an? Ich glaube, die meisten Wissenschaftler würden mit dem ASA anfangen, also mit dem Advanced Synthetic Aperture Radar, der die Physik der Ozeane und des Eises abtasten soll, aber auch für Landeinsätze sehr, sehr gute Dienste geleistet hat. Wir haben damit die Dynamik des arktischen Eises, aber auch der Antarktik beobachtet. Wir haben sehr viel über signifikante Wellenhöhen über dem Ozean kennengelernt. Wir haben, ich weiß nicht, ob du dich erinnerst, 2002 die große Elbeüberflutung. Wir konnten die Ausdehnung dieser Überflutungen und den Rückgang der Überflutung deutlich kartieren. Wir haben durch das Leben von Envisat öfter mal Datensätze an Hilfstruppen zur Verfügung gestellt. Wir haben das auch benutzt dann später in der...
Auch wahrscheinlich fürs ZKI beim DLR, dieses Zentrum für Kriseninformation.
Ja, die dann auch wieder zusammenarbeiten mit unserer Charter on Space and Major Disasters, die eigentlich auch sich sehr stark auf Envisat gestützt hat. Diese Charter wurde vor über 10 Jahren, ich glaube 11 Jahren, sie gegründet. Und Envisat war einer der ganz großen Datenlieferanten für die Charter, über 380 Mal, glaube ich, aktiviert zu Zeiten von Envisat. Und der ASA hat also dann auch in Krisengebieten, wo du halt mit dem konventionellen optischen Instrument nicht gucken kannst, weil da gerade eben eine große Flutkatastrophe ist oder was weiß ich, und du starke Regenfälle hast oder starke Wolkenbedeckung. Da war der ASA auf Envisat sehr nützlich, hat auch geholfen bei diesen großen Zyklonen. Da hat man dann die Wirbel auch im Wasser gesehen und Greenland abschmelzen. Also sehr, sehr viele Einsätze für Land, See und Eis. Und über Land natürlich ganz berühmt geworden durch diese Schneisen, die in die Tropenwälder geschlagen wurden. Wir haben viel Daten für das Forest Resource Assessment gegeben. Und oftmals auch so eine kleine Anekdote ist, das illegale Abholzen hat ja praktisch von den Straßen weg ein paar hundert Meter in den Tropenwald erst stattgefunden. So wenn die Waldinspektionen der Straßen entlang gefahren sind, dann waren die im Glauben, aha, dieser Tropenwald, der ist unberührt. Und aus dem Satellitenbild sah man dann natürlich das, was von hinten der Fraß kam. Fünfzig Meter dahinter, der Tropenwald bereits abgeholzt war. Eins der ganz größten Achievements war dann die Ozeanverschmutzung durch Öl. Und zwar nicht nur die ungewollte, wie der Unfall des Prestigetankers oder die Deepwater Horizon. Weil das Radarsignal natürlich auf diese durch das Öl geglättete Wasseroberfläche anders reagiert als auf unverschmutztes Wasser. Und auch da haben wir zum Eindämmung dieser Ölteppiche wunderbare Daten liefern können. Und mittlerweile in Norwegen operationell gemacht, hat man die Daten ausgewertet, welche Tanker-Betreiber oder Tankschiffbetreiber in der Nacht bei der Durchfahrt des Ärmelkanals vor allem oder anders, wo ihre Tanks gespült haben. Und diese Ölteppiche hat man dann sichtbar machen können. Und hat dann zusammen mit dem Automatic Identification of Ship, dem AIS-System, hat man die Leute dann zur Rechenschaft gezogen, auch finanziell. Und das funktioniert ganz gut, das ist ein Operal.
Also es hat als Beweis dann auch funktioniert. Kurzer Hinweis noch zur Auswertung von solchen Informationen, die von Erdbeobachtungssatelliten kommen. Raumzeit 25 war ein Gespräch eben über das Zentrum für Kriseninformationen, was ich schon erwähnt hatte beim DLR, Tobias Schneiderhahn. Und da sind auch noch sehr viele weitere Beispiele, wie da der Informationsfluss läuft und wofür Informationen aus der Erdbeobachtung eben noch verwendet werden können, abgesehen jetzt von der rein wissenschaftlichen Nutzung. Ja, also das ist diese SAR-Technologie, die es ja auch in einige Nachfolgeprojekte schon geschafft hat, wie schon erwähnt. TerraSAR und TandemX dabei, glaube ich, sind wohl die derzeit bemerkenswertesten Nachfolger. Was gab es noch auf dem Envisat?
Bevor ich weitergehe, du hast es mit TandemX angesprochen. Gerade also die Vulkanologie und die Seismik und Erdbeben, da hat uns der ASA dann, würde ich sagen, die unerwartetsten und eigentlich mit die wichtigsten Einsichten gewährt. Das große Sendai-Erdbeben in Japan. Wir haben mit ASA wirklich vermessen können, dass sich Japan um fast zweieinhalb Meter nach Westen verschoben hat. Wir haben den Ätna beim Atmen beobachtet. Um es eine Vorstellung zu haben, durch das Aufblähen der Magma kann man den sich auch der Berg aus. Natürlich nicht sichtbar fürs Auge, da handelt es sich um wenige Zentimeter. Und das war sichtbar gemacht worden durch Envisat. Und da war dann klar, dass ein großes Potential in der Erdbebenforschung, in der Vulkanologie, aber auch bei drohenden Hangrutschungen. Oder wenn sich große Landstriche verschieben. Wir haben beobachtet, wie sich Paris durch den U-Bahnbau oder Wasserextraktion um einen Zentimeter gesenkt hat oder zwei Zentimeter gesenkt hat. Das sind schon tolle Sachen. Auch natürlich, wenn irgendwo eine Gefährdung ansteht. Wir haben bei Gasfeldern und Erdölfeldern das Absenken des Bodens durch die Extraktion der Mineralressourcen feststellen können. Um das jetzt den Saar abzuschließen, das war mit das größte Potenzial, das der Saar uns gegeben hat. Diese Interferometrie, die wir nicht erwartet hatten. Dann gehe ich gleich auf die Atmosphärenchemie. Dieses Trio von Gomos, Mipas und Skia-Maki hat dann sehr viel zur Kartierung der Luftqualität, zur Ozonproblematik, zum Studium der Treibhausgase.
Kannst du das nochmal wiederholen, was die Abkürzungen bedeuten?
Gomos ist das Global Ozone Monitoring by Occultation of Stars. Ich habe vorhin Sun gesagt, aber das sind natürlich Stars. Was der gemacht hat, der schaut sich die Sterne an und hält die fest und hat eine Referenz dieses Sternenlichts. Wenn der Envisat dann um die Erde herumfliegt, dann geht dieser Blickvektor, der verschwindet dann in der Atmosphäre. Aber er bleibt auf dem Stern und sieht sich, wie das Sternenlicht im Hintergrund der Atmosphäre verändert. Diese Veränderung nimmt der Satellit als Spektrum auf und sieht, was da für Inhaltsstoffe in dieser Luftsäule, in diesem Luftvektor zum Stern sind. Das kann er dann spektroskopisch analysieren und dann weiß er, was ist da drin, wie viel O3, wie viel Stickoxide etc.
Und das macht er nicht nur mit einem Stern, sondern mit so ziemlich allen Sternen, die da vorbeikommen?
Der hat Referenzsterne.
Das heißt, er kann so permanent eigentlich immer durch den Horizont durchschauen und vergleicht es.
Er ist permanent im Einsatz und er guckt immer in die Nacht. Er guckt nie auf die Erde in den Tag. Und das wurde dann komplettiert durch den MIPAS, Michelson Interferometer for Passive Atmospheric Sounding. Der hat in zwei Richtungen geguckt, seitlich raus, also vom Satelliten seitlich weg und nach hinten. Und der hat versucht, Temperaturfelder in Höhenabhängigkeit, aber natürlich auch Ozon genau zu kartieren.
Wie hoch fliegt der Envisat?
800 Kilometer, ich glaube 802.
Also ziemlich weit draußen.
Na ja, gut. Also gemessen an so einem Geostationären, der ist 36.000 Kilometer.
Ja gut, aber mit einer Erdbeobachtung spielt sich das meistens doch eher darunter ab. Und auch die ISS ist ja viel weiter unten.
Die ist noch viel weiter unten. Aber die erreicht natürlich auch nicht diese Beobachtungsbedeckung. Denn von der ISS ist es beim 60. Breitengrad zu Ende, nach oben sowie nach unten. Also nördliche bis südliche Halbkuppel. Na ja, und dann hatten wir neben diesem Gromos und dem Mipas hatten wir den Schiamaki und das ist eine etwas komplizierte Abkürzung. Scanning Imaging Absorption Spectrometer for Atmospheric Cartography. Und die haben alle in verschiedenen Spektralbereichen gearbeitet. Also der Schiamaki, der hat also im Ultravioletten und im sichtbaren und im nahen Infrarot. Der Mipas, der hat im thermalen Infrarot. Und der Gomos, der hat auch im sichtbaren und im Infrarot gearbeitet. Die haben es ja so überlappt und haben die Spurengase in den verschiedenen Spektralbereichen beobachtet und in verschiedenen Richtungen. Und haben dadurch diese globalen Karten erstellt.
Aber die haben jetzt nicht alle diese Technik mit diesem Sternenlichtvergleich gemacht?
Nein, nein. Mipas hat sich auf die Emission, also diese Sternenlichtgeschichte ist die sogenannte Okkultationstechnik. Das heißt, du kennst die Lichtquelle. Und was immer zwischen dich und die Lichtquelle kommt, analysierst du dadurch, dass sich das Licht verändert. Der Mipas hat auf das Emissionsverhalten gezielt. Das heißt, was die Spurngase an Energie aufgenommen haben und wieder abgegeben hat, das misst er als Emissionsspektrometer. Und Skiamaki hat auch als sichtbare, also praktisch kriegt die Rückstreu-Signale vom Sonnenlicht, von den Spurngasen, von den Molekülen der Spurngase zurück. Und auch von den Aerosolen. Aerosole sind zum Teil also auch beobachtet worden.
Das heißt, diese drei Instrumente sind schon ein bisschen so ein eigenes Konzert auf dem Envisat gewesen, weil sie im Prinzip versucht haben, dasselbe herauszufinden, bloß alle unterschiedlichen Strategien dabei angewendet haben. Warum hat man das gemacht? Weil man wusste, dass man bei jedem einen anderen Aspekt bekommt? Oder geht es auch um die Vergleichbarkeit der Ergebnisse?
Na, es war schon komplementär. Das Komplementäre stand im Vordergrund. Wir wussten, dass solche Sachen wie z.B. CO2 und Methan mit Mipas und Gomos fast nicht möglich sind. Das hat man dann mit dem Skia-Maki gemacht. Gomos hat auch ganz gezielt... Da war die Stärke natürlich in den Ozon-Profilen. Mipas wieder die dazugehörige Temperatur. Es waren die Ingredienzen, die drei verschiedenen Instrumente, die die Band gut klingen lassen. Aber das ist jetzt sehr unwissenschaftlich ausgedrückt. Es gab überlappende Messungen, Hauptthema Ozon. Aber z.B. die Stickoxid-Familie von Mipas, die hat man aber auch ein bisschen mit Skia-Maki beobachtet, Industrie-Emissionen, wie wir am Anfang nicht geglaubt haben, dass wir sie messen würden können. Also N2O, NO2, N2O5, wir nennen es die Nitrox-Family. Da war dann der Mipas natürlich sehr, sehr stark. Und so haben die sich eigentlich sehr, sehr gut ergänzt.
Das heißt ja, Envisat war jetzt eigentlich auch das erste System, das so umfassend überhaupt Luftverschmutzung hat nachweisen können?
Ja, erstens das und zweitens hat es im Endeffekt dann auch, und das ist eigentlich ein Punkt, den man hier auch ganz dringend ansprechen muss, was als pure Science angefangen hat, hat nach ein paar Jahren dann fast operationellen Charakter angenommen. Und das beeinflusst uns auch heute und wie sich jetzt in den letzten Tagen herausstellt auch politisch.
Was meinst du damit? Also oberrationell im Sinne von, dass man...
Komme ich gleich drauf.
Ja, okay.
In dem Moment, wo du den Umweltministerien und ich glaube, das Bayerische Umweltministerium war eins der ersten, die Luftqualitätsabschätzungen aus Envisat routinemäßig versucht haben, zum Einsatz zu bringen. Die Engländer haben auf dem Luftqualitätsservice von Envisat einen Service basiert, wo Leute, die Atemwege erkrankten, Warnungen bekamen, wenn die Luftverschmutzung so hoch wurde, sie sollten nicht mehr auf die Straße gehen. Für die Tourismusindustrie hat man die UV-Strahlungsintensitäten, die man natürlich auch bekommen konnte, als Indikator für Warnungen genommen, für UV-Strahlungswarnungen, aber auch für in dem Moment, wo das Ozonloch zu groß wurde. Und in dem Moment, wo du solche Service-Einrichtungen betreibst und viele kleine und mittelständische Betriebe, die sich als Value-Adder damals hervorgetan haben, sind auch stabil im Geschäft geblieben, Gott sei Dank. Die haben dann diese Services angeboten und daraus entstand dann auch die Nachfrage für solche Services. Und im Grunde genommen kann man sagen, dass ein Großteil des heutigen GMES-Programms, und du wirst dir da ein eigenes Gespräch diesbezüglich führen, basieren auf den Envisat-Errungenschaften oder Achievements, wie wir sagen. Also da ist der Sentinel-1 auf den Asa, der Sentinel-3 bezieht sich jetzt, ich spring gleich zum Dreier, auf diese Ozeankombination von physikalischer und biologischer Ozeanbeobachtungen, und Sentinel-54, die Atmosphärenchemie, die von den drei Envisat-Konzertanten angefangen wurde. Und man sieht dann schon, dass irgendwann, wenn mal was operationell ist, geht es in eine operationelle Schiene, und dann trennt es sich von der Wissenschaft wieder.
Ist das etwas, was ihr bei der Planung von Envisat irgendwie schon im Kopf hattet? Oder war das schon eher Wunschvorstellungen, oder man hat das überhaupt nicht bedacht, dass dieser Satellit dann wirklich so tagesaktuelles Services unterstützt, die jetzt gar nicht unmittelbar für eine wissenschaftliche Auswertung, sondern quasi für eine Echtzeit- oder Kurzzeitmutzung gedacht waren?
Es ist so ähnlich wie heute. Wenn wir einen wissenschaftlichen Satelliten konzipieren, dann halten uns natürlich auch unsere Geldgeber immer an, dass das ein wissenschaftlich getriebenes Programm ist, ein science-driven Programm. Aber wir sehen im Vorfeld schon, dass wenn diese Beobachtung Qualität hat und gut ist, wenn das Ding läuft, wie man so schön sagt, dann kann die Nachfrage nach mehr kommen. Wir haben jetzt das Beispiel zum Beispiel mit SMOS, dieser Soil Moisture and Ocean Salinity Satellit, mit der wir die Bodenfeuchte beobachten. Es ist ganz klar, dass auf Jahre hinaus das ein Produkt ist, das operationell gebraucht werden wird. Am Anfang stand aber die Wissenschaft. Und mit den Wetter-Satelliten war es am Anfang ja auch so. Das waren wissenschaftliche Satelliten, die dann, als sie operationell wurden, von der ESA an Eumetsat, die europäische meteorologische Satellitenorganisation, übergeben wurden. Eumetsat wurde 1986 von der ESA ins Leben gerufen. Und die Meteosat-Satelliten, die wir für die neue Generation heute entwickeln, sobald diese Satelliten gut funktionieren, werden die sofort an Eumetsat übergeben. Wir arbeiten mittlerweile auch mit den Entwicklungsgeldern von Eumetsat, um gezielt für Eumetsat-Satelliten herzustellen. Und so ähnlich ist es natürlich mit Envisat, haben wir damals auch schon geahnt. Das könnte operationellen Charakter bekommen. Ozon-Monitoring, die Überwachung von Ozon auf lange Zeit hinaus, von Luftqualität auf lange Zeit hinaus. Aber zuerst mussten die wissenschaftlichen Schritte getan werden, bevor man sich auf operationelle Dienste verlegen konnte. Und wir haben damals auch gar nicht so sehr viel drüber gesprochen und das thematisiert, weil es war nicht nur Wunschdenken. Wir wussten nicht, welche Genauigkeiten wir erreichen. Wird das jemals die Qualität erreichen, die für den operationellen Service wichtig ist, war auch nicht im Vordergrund. Die Wissenschaft war im Vordergrund und für uns, die ESA als R&D-Organisation, ist sie das auch heute. Aber ich sehe heute schon, bin ja auch nur lange genug in diesem Feld, wenn Satelliten kommen, dass die durchaus operationelle Möglichkeiten haben können. Aber erst wenn die im Betrieb sind, diese Geräte oder diese Speer im All, wie man sie nennt, und wertvolle Datenströme liefern erst, dann kann man sagen, das lohnt sich weiter verfolgt zu werden. Und das passiert jetzt mit den Sentinels in GMS, die sich weitgehend, aber nicht ausschließlich, auf Envisat aufbauen.
Das ist ja so ein bisschen wieder Kern der Zyklus in der ganzen Raumfahrt. Das, was vor 30, 40 Jahren noch Forschung, Wissenschaft und Aufbruch zu neuen Ufern war, ist heute teilweise gängiger, normaler Betrieb von Raumfahrt für kommerzielle Zwecke. Der ganze Bereich von Telekommunikationssatelliten ist, glaube ich, das beste Beispiel. Fernsehen etc. Wo sich ja auch die ESA als wissenschaftliche Forschungsgruppe auch komplett raushält. An dieser Stelle bei der Erdbeobachtung, wahrscheinlich nicht nur da, ist das ja dann auch mal so ein Grenzbereich. Auf der einen Seite ist es noch neu und wird benötigt für neue wissenschaftliche Forschung. Auf der anderen Seite sieht man auch schon, dass man quasi zu einer Art wissenschaftlichen Dienstleister wird und damit neue Industrien heraufzieht. Ist das so ein Spagat? Macht das die wissenschaftliche Arbeit auch schwierig, wenn da immer so latent solche Anwendungen noch mit da drin stecken?
Macht es schwierig. Es ist, du hast eine Facette, Entschuldige, wenn ich da jetzt dazwischenkomme, bevor ich die Frage beantworte. Ich will nicht sagen vergessen, aber vielleicht ein bisschen übersehen, das ist die politische Dimension. Denn zwischen diesem wissenschaftlichen und dem bereits reifen Service ist dann immer noch die Beobachtung, die Anlass zu politischen Entscheidungen gibt. Da will ich jetzt mal unsere drei Atmosphären-Chemie-Instrumente in den Vordergrund heben, die aufgrund der genau vermessenen Ozonproblematik es geschafft haben, das Montreal-Protokoll zu beeinflussen. Und das sind ganz wichtige Entscheidungen. Und manchmal kann man sagen, dass unter Umständen der Service-Geschmack oder der operationelle Geschmack einer Anwendung oder eines Satelliten unter Umständen gegen ihn verwendet werden kann, dass er nicht als reine Science sich qualifiziert. Aber das, glaube ich, haben wir mittlerweile gerade in dieser Diskussion mit GMS und unseren Earth-Explorern gut im Griff, dass wir die wissenschaftliche Schiene von der operationellen zwar getrennt halten, aber versuchen, die eine schlussendlich in die andere übergehen zu lassen. Das haben wir gelernt. Es war am Anfang nicht einfach, insofern ist die Frage berechtigt, aber ich glaube, heute haben wir das gut im Griff.
Kommen wir mal zu den anderen Instrumenten, die wir bisher noch nicht besprochen haben. Wir hatten jetzt diese drei Atmosphärenbeobachter, der GOMOS, Mipas, Giamacci, das AASA, ganz zu Beginn. Was ist das?
Dann gab es den Meeres, das Medium Resolution Imaging Spectrometer. Das war eine ganz tolle Maschine. Das war im Grunde genommen das erste Imaging Spectrometer, abbildende Spektrometer. Wir hatten schon einen kleinen Vorläufer, den Chris auf Probe, ein ganz kleines Instrument. Aber von dieser Größe und dieser Qualität hat es so ein Instrument vorher nicht gegeben. Mit den Meeres haben wir das Phytoplankton in den Ozeanen angeschaut und wollten Aufschlüsse über die biologische Produktivität der Ozeane gewinnen.
Bei Meeres ging es explizit um die Meere. Das war ein Instrument, das sich nur darauf konzentriert hat.
Zielsetzung Meere und natürlich Atmosphäre. Denn um das gute Meeresignal der Ozeane. Und da kommt sehr wenig an Lichtenergie von der Sonne rückgestrahlt zurück. Es war also ein Hochpräzisionsspektrometer, das auf leichteste oder geringste Photonenströme vom Wasser reagiert. Und der hat vor allem das grüne Phytoplankton, aber auch Gelbstoff oder Yellow Substance, das ist das organisch zersetzte Material, das in die Ozeane einfließt, und Sedimentströme beobachtet. Wir haben viel da über die Ozeanbiologie verstanden. Wir haben auch viele toxische oder giftige Alpenblüten beobachtet, die dazu geführt haben, dass Fischfarmbetreiber dann aufgrund von Meeresbeobachtungen ihre Fischfarmen umgelegt oder verlagert haben. Wir haben viel über die Wasserqualität in Küstenbereichen gelernt. Und natürlich wurden die Sedimentbeobachtungen auch von solchen, die sich mit Hafeneinfahrten beschäftigt benutzen. Da ist unheimlich viel passiert. Wie ich vorhin schon erwähnt habe, kommen die Leute, die sich für Landanwendungen interessieren und nehmen die Datensätze über Land. Auch da haben wir sehr viel über die Vegetation gelernt. Über Vegetationsverhalten, über Vegetationsschäden, über Vegetationsrückgang, Dynamik in verschiedenen Bereichen. Wir haben die großen Dürrekatastrophen. 2003 auf der Iberischen Halbinsel und in Frankreich. Solche Sachen haben wir da beobachtet.
Also man konnte ja sozusagen sehen, wie die Vegetation leidet.
Man konnte sehen, wie sie leidet, wie sie sich verändert. Man konnte auch gestresste Vegetationen von gesunder Vegetation unterscheiden. Da gab es also verschiedene Ansätze, auch für Landmanagement. Wir haben Anbauflächen beobachtet. Und es sind unheimlich viele Resultate aus mehres gekommen. Der Sensor ist im Endeffekt sehr viel universeller gewesen, als wir es geglaubt haben. Wir haben sogar die Fluoreszenz von Plankton im Wasser beobachten können. Eine tolle technische Meisterleistung, das Instrument wurde damals noch aerospacial, heute ist es Thales Alenia in Frankreich, in Cannes, gebaut. Der Projektmanager hätte mich damals beinahe gefressen, weil mit den Wissenschaftlern zusammen, ich war der Secretary oder der Convener dieser Wissenschaftlichen Beratergruppe, haben wir das Instrument programmierbar gemacht. D.h. die Spektralbänder, genauso wie die Bodenauflösung von dem Gerät, waren programmierbar. Man konnte vom Boden aus die Spektralbänder in dem Spektrometer platzieren, was natürlich für das Operationsschema...
Also im laufenden Betrieb sozusagen.
Und für jeden Satellitenoperateur ist das ein absoluter Albtraum. Und ich musste dem Projektmanager damals in die Hand versprechen, dass wir nach dem Start nur ein- oder zweimal...
Warum ist das ein Albtraum für den Operateur?
In dem Moment, wo man eine Nutzergemeinschaft aufbaut, die an ihre 15 Spektraldatensätze gewohnt ist. Und dann kommt plötzlich einer daher, der will was anderes. Und man ändert das. Dann würfelst du die gesamte Nutzergemeinschaft durcheinander und enttäuschst die einen und erfreust die anderen. Aber auch im Missionsbetrieb, solche Operationen, solche Telecommands, das ist immer alles eine kitzelige Angelegenheit. Da oben, das ist ein feindliches Environment in puncto Temperatur und Strahlung da im Weltraum. Da will man nicht zu viel rumspielen. Wenn so ein Satellit mehr funktioniert, dann sollte man ihn am besten in Ruhe lassen. Wir haben es mit Meres so gemacht, dass die Startvibrationen in der Start, das ist eine starke Belastung für Satelliten, da kommt schon mal eine leichte Dejustierung hier und da vor. Wir haben diese Programmierbarkeit des Satelliten benutzt, um die Bänder richtig justiert einzusetzen und genau in diese Absorbtionsbande zu bringen, wo entweder Atmosphären oder Oberflächenphänomene wie das Plankton im Ozean das Licht entweder reflektieren oder absorbieren. Das haben wir uns angeguckt. Ganz am Anfang haben wir für die Kalibration alle Bänder mal nebeneinander, um so eine Spektralkurve zu sehen. Das hat uns eigentlich deutlich Einsichten, nicht nur wissenschaftlicher, auch technischer Art und Weise, gegeben. Das hat sich in Retrospect als die richtige Entscheidung rausgestellt. Nachdem wir den Satelliten eingestellt haben, haben wir dann auch das Versprechen dem Projektmanager gegenüber gehalten und haben eigentlich den Bandsatz des Bands nicht mehr verändert. Auch um die Nutzer-Community einen steten und kontinuierlichen Datensatz bekommen zu lassen.
Das ist das, was man glaube ich nicht so im Kopf hat bei solchen Projekten. Dass da einfach einerseits viele Ingenieure am Werk sind und Leute das Ganze natürlich dann auch betreiben und rund um die Uhr beobachten. Aber dahinter ist ja noch eine viel größere Gruppe von Wissenschaftlern, die einfach dann diesen kontinuierlichen, also im Idealfall kontinuierlichen Datenstrom eben auch konsequent umsetzen und von jeder weiteren Minute an Datenfluss profitieren und dann natürlich ein bisschen verwirrt sind, wenn sich auf einmal die Struktur des Datenstroms ändert.
Und weißt du, hier ist auch diese wunderbare Zusammenarbeit mit den Ingenieuren. Wir haben damals, wenn du natürlich jetzt so ganz schwache Signale vom Ozean angucken willst, dann sagst du dir, okay, dann baue ich da einen Verstärker ein. Das ist genau wie ein Geräuschverstärker bei leiser Musik. Du versuchst also, das letzte Signal rauszukitzeln. Oh je, oh je, wenn ich über eine Wolke fliege, dann verbrennen mir meine Detektoren. Das geht ja gar nicht. Ja, wie mache ich jetzt das? Also man versucht dann zu sagen, okay, dann schauen wir die Wolken nicht an, dann schauen wir das Land nicht an, jetzt konzentrieren wir uns auf den Ozean. Da kommt plötzlich ein Ingenieur, der sagt, also wir können eigentlich den Gain oder den Verstärkungsfaktor, könnten wir für euch regeln. Also wenn ihr wollt, können wir das so machen, dass ihr nicht nur überm Wasser was seht, sondern auch über Land. Sagenhaft prima.
Man kombiniert sozusagen die Instrumente gleich untereinander.
In einem, bzw. man macht das Missionsprofil so, dass die Detektoren eben nicht verbrennen, aber dass durch einen einstellbaren sogenannten Gain oder Verstärkungsfaktor du nicht übersteuerst, wenn du über Wolken fliegst, und du das Maximum aus deinem Signal rausholst, wenn du über den Ozean fliegst. Na gut, das haben wir dann gemacht. Plötzlich war die Landnutzergemeinschaft da, die Wissenschaftler, und haben sie irrsinnig gefreut. Ein Professor aus Berlin kam danach und sagte, jetzt würde mich aber interessieren, ob wir die Wolken nicht auch noch angucken können. Da war die Frage, warum das denn? Wir wollen gerne die Wolkenhöhe bestimmen anhand der O2-Absorption. Die ist so schmal, und die kann man nur mit einem Spektrometer sehen. Sonst sieht man das nicht. Aber wenn man die O2-Absorption bestimmen kann, kann man Wolkenhöhen bestimmen. Also zurück zum Ingenieur. Und der hat gesagt, klar, machen wir, logisch. Und so ist aus einem sehr, sehr gezielten Ozeaninstrument eins geworden, dass die Atmosphären sowie die Lands, sowie die ozeanografische Wissenschaftsgemeinschaft wirklich bedient hat. Und tolle Resultate haben die rausgesucht, wirklich gut.
Wolkenland und Wasser, alles in allem. Das war Meeres.
Tja, jetzt kommt noch ein richtiges Juwel. Es sind eigentlich alle Juwelen. Und man sollte keins hervornehmen. Das ist unser Radar-Altimeter. Das Radar-Altimeter, also ein Höhenmessgerät, wirft Pulse vom Satelliten auf den Boden und versieht die mit einem Timetag und misst genau die Delay-Time oder die Verzögerung, die das Signal braucht vom Satelliten runter zum Wasser und wieder zurück.
Nur zum Wasser?
Ja, über Land geht es auch. Aber da komme ich noch drauf. Wichtig war über Wasser. Und wenn man jetzt den Satelliten anschaut mit seinen verschiedenen anderen Instrumenten, mit seiner Lageregelung, mit seinen Sonnen- und Erdsensoren, wo es immer auf den Horizont guckt, im Endeffekt liegt so ein Satellit in einer ultra-stabilen Flugbahn und hat eine derart exakte geometrische Referenz, dass man auf Zentimeter genau den Abstand vom Satelliten zur Meeressoberfläche vermessen kann. Und die Satellitenflugbahn, die verändert sich da nicht so sehr, aber der Meeresspiegel verändert sich. Und darum funktioniert das wie ein Höhenmessgerät. Das ist gerade gesagt. Hat uns geholfen über die Jahre in Kombination mit dem baugleichen Altimeter auf, ja nicht ganz baugleich, es war eine Weiterentwicklung, aber im Grunde genommen vom Prinzip her ähnlich funktionierenden Altimeter auf ERS 1, ERS 2, hat Envisat dann fortgesetzt, die Meeresspiegelschwankungen und damit auch den Meeresspiegelanstieg zu vermessen. Zusammen mit dem französischen Radaraltimeter TopEx Poseidon, eine nationale Entwicklung, und mit den Altimetern der Amerikaner haben wir es also geschafft, von 1991 mit ERS angefangen, bis jetzt eine Zeitserie darzustellen, die deutlich den Meeresspiegelanstieg mit ca. 3,14 Millimetern pro Jahr zu zeigen. In einer Genauigkeit, wie sie von Land aus nie gemessen hätte werden können.
Und da waren auch jetzt die Ergebnisse von ERS und von Envisat dann auch so kombinierbar?
Die waren kombinierbar. Und da gab es also ein Wissenschaftlerteam aus Amerikanern, ein Holländer, der lange Zeit in Amerika war. Die haben die Daten auch dann prozessiert, haben die Bias, die rausgeholt, haben die Datensätze homogenisiert und auf eine Reihe gebracht. Und die widersprechen sich nicht. Im Gegenteil, die bestätigen einander. Und das war der unwiederlegbare Beweis des Meeresspiegelanstiegs. Rückführbar auf das Abschmelzen von antarktischem Eis, von Grönlandeis und natürlich auch von Abfluss von Gletschern und Schneeflächen und Permafrost in die Weltmeere. Wir haben natürlich auch die Bestätigung durch die Erwärmung der Arktis gesehen und die Abnahme der Arktis, die 2007 zum ersten Mal wieder die Nordwest- und Nordost-Passage gleichbar schiffbar gemacht hat. Das waren mehr Beobachtungen, die dann mit dem Saar hergehen. Aber diese Treibhausgas oder Global Warming-Problematik wurde damit ganz eindeutig belegt. Und vom Boden aus wären diese Messungen einfach nicht möglich gewesen. Und dann sind wir durch die Instrumente fast durch. Denn der Laser Reflektor und die Doppler Orbitography haben natürlich den Radaraltimeter in ihrer Flugbahn Genauigkeitsbestimmung unterstützt. Und damit das Signal vom Radaraltimeter nicht durch Luftfeuchtigkeit beeinflusst wird, hat man ein Mikrowellen-Radiometer, das zehnte Instrument, dem Radaraltimeter zur Seite gestellt, um diesen Weg durch den Wasserdampf zu korrigieren. Also eine ziemlich knifflige Technologie und wissenschaftlich ausgetüftelte Kombination von Instrumenten, die da ultragenau zur Höhenbestimmung geführt hat. Wir haben es dann auch über Eis gemacht. Und anhand dieser verschiedenen Radaraltimeter haben wir es dann zum ersten Mal auch geschafft, die Antarktis so ein bisschen zu vermessen. Weil so richtige Höhenprofile von der Antarktis gab es ja da auch gar nicht. Und da hat der Radaraltimeter auch fantastische Dienste geleistet. Ein Instrument zum Schluss, das war ein Beitrag von Großbritannien, das war das Along-Track Scanning Radiometer. Das war in vorhergehenden Versionen schon auf RS1 und RS2 geflogen. Und das hat die Temperatur der Ozeane gemessen. Hat uns geholfen, El Nino und La Nina Phänomene zu sehen.
Also diese temporäre Erwärmung oder Abkühlung des pazifischen Bereichs.
Durch diese westlichen Trade Winds, die sich da verändern. Und das war ganz sagenhaft, denn in Kombination mit dem Radaraltimeter, von eben erwähnt, hat man also diese Strömungsrücken gesehen, die sich bei diesem El Nino, bei dieser Zunge da, auf die Westküste Amerikas zu bewegen. Und dort dann diese Überflutungen und diese Wetteranomalien auslösen. Und da war der ATSR fantastisch. Der war also supergut und hat das prima vermessen. Wir haben auch an den Zeitserien, man muss ja denken, der ATSR hat ja nicht erst mit Envisat angefangen. Die waren ja schon auf ERS 1 1991. Bis 2012 hat man natürlich die Erwärmung der Ozeane über die Jahre feststellen können. Wie genau? Wir haben eine Genauigkeit von einem Grad Kelvin oder einem Grad aufs Grad genau. Und das war natürlich auch eine Errungenschaft.
Mit welcher Auflösung muss man sich das denken? Wie groß wird da so geschaut? Das ist jetzt nicht so der Quadratmeter, sondern wir reden hier von Quadratkilometern.
Nein, die Bodenpixelgröße von ATSR, wenn ich mich nicht irrelag, bei 500 Metern. Ein Bildpunkt war 500 Meter. Das ist völlig ausreichend, wenn man über Weltmeere spricht. Wenn man versucht, in der Städteplanung tätig zu sein, kann man mit so einer Auflösung mit anpacken.
Bei der Temperaturmessung taucht es vielleicht nicht so.
Aber für die globale Erwärmung war das gut. Wie auch bei vielen anderen Instrumenten, man sollte nicht zu sehr abschweifen, ein ganz wichtiger Punkt, der nicht vorhersehbar war, bei ATSR, die haben es mit dem kurzwelligen Kanal geschafft, Waldbrände aufzunehmen. Da wurden dann Forest Fire Atlanten gemacht. Das heißt, man hat Zeitserien von globalen Waldbränden gemacht. Das war auch hochinteressant. Man konnte also auch sehen, wo große Waldbrände in Afrika, aber auch in Griechenland und Portugal, diese Waldbrände haben wir gesehen. Daraus wurde dann der World Fire Atlas. Der Weltbrandatlas wurde dann da erhoben. Man hat nicht nur die großen Vegetationsfeuer gesehen, auch von der Abholzung oder der Rotung der Tropenwälder, was auch wieder ein politischer Input war, sondern man hat auch gesehen diese Umweltbrände, die da die Welt belasten.
Wie lange dauert das eigentlich, bis Envisat einmal komplett die Oberfläche immer überflogen hat? Also dass jeder Teil beobachtet werden konnte von jedem Instrument? Oder zumindest jetzt auch spezifisch in diesem Fall? Also wie lange, wie viel Zeit vergeht? Wie vollständig kann so ein Feueratlas zum Beispiel sein? Also braucht der dann ein paar Tage, bis er mal wieder vorbeikommt?
Der Feueratlas braucht ein paar Tage, weil der Schwad von ATSR jetzt nicht ganz so breit war. Ich weiß jetzt auswendig nicht mehr genau, wie breit der war. Ich kann ja sagen, der Merris Schwad, der war 1150 Kilometer breit. Gut, ich habe mit dem Instrument, der war so ein bisschen mein Baby, ja sehr viel gearbeitet. Und mit diesen 1150 Kilometern hat Merris eine globale Bedeckung am Äquator nach drei Tagen erreicht. Das heißt, du hast die Erde einmal kartiert gehabt. Natürlich waren da auch Wolken drauf. Denn wir müssen ja immer von einer statistischen Wolkenbedeckung ausgehen. Insofern, um ein wolkenfreies Bild der Erde zu bekommen, dauert das viel länger. Und manche Gebiete, wie jetzt in Südamerika, Amazonas, Deltas und solche Ecken, wo wir sehr viel Wolkenbedeckung haben, die kriegst du sehr selten. In unseren breiten Graden, also jetzt im Mitteleuropa, hatten wir fast alle zwei Tage, oder alle zwei Tage hatten wir, nicht fast, sondern wirklich nach zwei Tagen, war also praktisch vom 40. breiten Grad hoch, war alles bedeckt.
Nur so die Polregionen, die wurden permanent überflogen. Also da hat man keinen einzigen Waldbrand verpasst sozusagen.
Und ich meine, die Abtaststreifen dieser Atmosphären-Chemie-Instrumenten, die waren natürlich viel größer, da hat man also noch viel mehr Beobachtungen bekommen. Der Radar wurde in verschiedenen Beobachtungsmodi eingesetzt. Da gab es so einen Global-Mode, mit einem 1.000 Kilometer-Sport und einer groben Auflösung, 500 Kilometer, da hat man natürlich auch sehr viel schneller die Erde beobachtet, aber die hauptsächlichen Nutzer wollten im normalen Imaging-Mode, also mit der 20 Meter Auflösung. Und da will man auch, vom ASA wollte man keine globalen Karten, globalen Bedeckungen haben, sondern das wollte man also gezielt zusammensetzen. Obwohl man für Landoberflächen, also wir haben dann aus Meeres ein globales Landcover-Mapping gemacht. Und da hat man dann die verschiedenen Orbits zusammengesetzt, um eine Landflächenklassifizierung zu machen. Also Global Maps haben wir dann auch zusammengesetzt und die haben halt die Daten über mehrere Tage gesammelt.
Aber man sieht jetzt auch diese ganzen Szenarien mit dem operationellen Nutzen und der potenziellen Dienstleistung für Wirtschaft, Politik und eigentlich alle Bereiche der Gesellschaft. Wenn man sich das anschaut, dann ist es doch eigentlich extrem erstrebenswert, auch ein Instrument zu haben, was mehr oder weniger, naja, ich sage jetzt mal, nicht alles in Echtzeit anschaut, aber wo auch so Zyklen wie drei Tage noch deutlich reduziert werden können. Ich denke mal, diese eine Maßnahme mit diesem sechsten Element, was man da noch eingespart hat, was am Ende nicht zu einer Einsparung geführt hat, aber die Sicht eingeschränkt hat, das hat ja dann sozusagen auch genau das System in diesem Leistungsbereich beschränkt. Man konnte nicht mehr so breit gucken, also braucht es länger, bis man dieselbe Stelle wieder mal sieht. Ist das überhaupt erstrebenswert? Ist das andererseits auch realisierbar? Oder ist das zu viel Anforderungen? Oder ist das eigentlich genau das, was man will? Dass man jeden Tag ein komplettes Bild der Erde bekommt mit allen Instrumenten?
Es kommt ganz aufs Phänomen drauf an. Also bei Meres haben wir ein klein wenig drunter gelitten, weil wir sehr viel Streustrahlung vom sogenannten Sand glennt, der Sonnenreflektion im nicht günstigen Einfallswinkel auf dem Wasser bekommen hat. Und hätten wir dieses Modul noch gehabt, das hätte uns ein bisschen geholfen. Aber im Grunde genommen haben wir alle Missionsziele nicht nur erreicht, sondern übertroffen. Insofern war es nicht schlimm. Und ich kann die Entscheidung im Nachhinein auch verstehen. Wir haben es mitgetragen, kein Problem. Das sind auch Sachen, die man lernt. In dem Moment, wo man aber jetzt für Kriseneinsätze oder für sich schnell verändernde dynamische Phänomene...
Also ein Waldbrand kann ja nach drei Tagen auch schon wieder vorbei sein.
Wobei, das muss man auch sagen, ATSR nie als Missionszielsetzung die Waldbrände hat. Das war ein Ozeanthermometer. Und vom Ozeanthermometer zu einem Waldbrandkartierer ist ein weiter Weg. Und er hat es trotzdem super gut gemacht. Drei Tage für einen Waldbrand ist schon... Wir haben Waldbrände, die sehr viel länger brennen und über längere Zeiten hinweg. Man kann es dann auch sehen, welche sind von kurzer Dauer. Man hat diese in saisonaler Abhängigkeit sowie in Wetterabhängigkeit diese Waldbrände. Die kann man dann auch lernen zu unterscheiden.
Sind ja nicht von heute auf morgen vorbei.
Das wollte ich damit sagen. Ganz interessant, diese kurzen Beobachtungszeiten, die brauchen wir wirklich mehr auf der operationellen Seite, also für Krisengeräte, für Wettervorhersagen, für dynamische Ozeanphänomene, die wir also sehr schnell wieder sehen wollen. Da ist das angebracht. Aber für die wissenschaftlichen Satelliten, die wir da benutzen, bzw. die wir studieren, brauchen wir nicht immer near real time, wie wir so schön sagen, globale Bedeckung von allem.
Jetzt ist Envisat deutlich länger gelaufen, wir haben es schon erwähnt, als die ursprünglich mal anvisierten oder zumindest garantierten fünf Jahre. Es waren dann zehn Jahre. Tatsächlich ist es im März dieses Jahres. Im April dieses Jahres dann auf einmal schlagartig. Es gab nichts, wodurch sich das jetzt besonders angekündigt hätte, dass der Satellit außer Betrieb ging. Gibt es denn Theorien dazu, was ihn jetzt zur Strecke gebracht hat?
Wir haben bei der ESA den Mechanismus von sogenannten Investigation Boards. Da wird ein Team von Spezialisten zusammengeholt, wenn eine Anomalie ganz gleich in welchem Bereich passiert.
Also es wird ja vor allem auch erst mal probiert, das Ding wieder zum Leben zu erwecken.
Das haben wir natürlich sofort probiert. Aber da war gleich klar, dass der Satellit nicht kommuniziert. Das heißt, er war also wie Taubstum da oben. Wir haben ihn angefunkt, kein Signal zurückbekommen. Er hat nichts runtergefunkt. Und dann hat man das versucht, aber sofort ein Investigation Board aufgesetzt. Und die sind mit zwei möglichen Ursachen gekommen. Und das eine ist ein Ausfall eines Leistungsreglers, wodurch die Telemetrie- und die Fernsteuerung blockiert worden sind, weil wir konnten den Satelliten auch nicht mehr steuern. Und das andere war unter Umständen ein Kurzschluss, durch den der Satellit in den abgesicherten Modus, den sogenannten Safe Mode, reintriftet, wo er sich dann nach der Sonne ausrichtet, um überleben zu können und immer von der Erde ansprechbar zu sein. Aber den Modus des Überlebens, diesen Safe Modus oder Überlebensmodus hat er nicht erreicht. Er ist auf dem halben Weg dahin, in der Halbendrehung stehen geblieben. Und man kann sich das nur so erklären, dass es dann eine zweite Anomalie gegeben hat. Also entweder Leistungsreglerausfall oder Kurzschluss. Das Fraunhofer-Institut hat dann freundlicherweise mit einem Radar, das gegen den Gehen Himmel schaut, den Envisat gescannt und abgebildet. RapidEye, diese hochauflösenden optischen Satelliten, haben ihn von oben fotografiert, als sie an ihm vorbeigeflogen sind. Wir haben festgestellt, dass er nicht auseinandergebrochen ist. Er ist immer noch in einem Stück. Er ist unverletzt. Er scheint völlig in Ordnung, nur eben leicht gedreht. Obwohl wir keinen Signal mehr kriegen, wird doch immer noch ab und zu versucht, ihn anzusprechen, ihn anzusteuern. Die Gefahr ist natürlich groß, dass, wenn der zweite Fehlerfall eingetreten ist, dann sind die Batterien wahrscheinlich schon leer und dann ist mit ihm nichts mehr anzufahren. Das ist natürlich sehr schade. Wir hätten gerne gehabt, dass der Satellit noch eineinhalb Jahre lebt. Wir hoffen, dass wir nächstes Jahr den ersten Sentinel, den Sentinel-1, starten können. Dann im Jahr drauf Sentinel-2 und Sentinel-3. Diese drei Satelliten hätten die Einzelfunktionen von Envisat, abgesehen von der Atmosphärenchemie, übernommen. Die kommen dann ein paar Jahre später mit Sentinel-4 und Sentinel-5. Da sprechen wir also von der zweiten Hälfte dieser Dekade. Das haben wir eben nicht geschafft. Wir haben jetzt da ein kleines Zeitloch drin, ohne Envisat. Da versuchen wir uns zu behelfen, dadurch, dass wir Daten teilen mit anderen Satellitenbetreibern aus Amerika, aus Kanada, aus Japan und überall aus der Welt. Wir werden abkommen und versuchen, unsere Datennutzer auch mit Daten von anderen Satelliten zu versorgen. Gleichzeitig schieben wir natürlich an, dass wir das GMES-Programm in seinen Sentinels schnell auf den Weg bekommen. Was die Wissenschaft anlangt, haben wir unser Explorer-Programm, unser Erdbeobachtungs-Envelope-Programm, wo lauter gezielte wissenschaftliche Satelliten weiterhin auf die Startrampen kommen. Aber mit Envisat haben wir natürlich schon einen sehr, sehr großen Beitrag, den wir in der Erdbeobachtung bisher haben durften. Den haben wir damit verloren.
In gewisser Hinsicht ist das Projekt wahrscheinlich noch nicht zu Ende, weil das Datenmaterial, was bis dahin aufgelaufen ist, bis er sich nicht mehr gemeldet hat, das dürfte wahrscheinlich den Wissenschaftlern noch auf lange Zeit Futter geben, oder?
Absolut. Wir haben über 4000 wissenschaftliche Projekte mit Envisat-Daten gefüttert. Wir haben fast 2000 peer-reviewed wissenschaftliche Publikationen, in denen der Envisat im Titel vorkommt. Unheimlich viele Workshops, die sich auf Envisat-Daten stützen. Die Nutzergemeinschaft ist mit diesen Wissenschaftsprojekten, von denen ich gerade sprach, derart groß, dass die weiterhin mit Envisat-Daten und auf Jahre hinaus arbeiten werden. Ganz wichtig in unserer Klima- und Umweltforschung sind natürlich Zeitserien wichtig. Wir werden genauso wenig die ERS-Daten vergessen wie die Envisat-Daten. Wenn wir später mit Sentinel-Daten arbeiten, werden unsere Klima- und Umweltforschung sicherlich die ganzen Zeitserien dieser Daten nehmen, benutzen, reprozessieren und versuchen, in Informationen umzusetzen, die uns auch dann längerfristige Vorhersagen auf Umwelt- und Klimageschehen ermöglichen.
Ja, haben wir noch was Wichtiges vergessen zu erwähnen?
Im Augenblick kann ich nur sagen, dass wir ganz sicherlich irgendwas oder mehrere Dinge vergessen haben, weil Envisat an sich ist so ein großes Stück Erdbeobachtungsgeschichte, dass man in der Zeit nicht alles abklopfen kann. Aber ich glaube, wir sind alle sehr stolz auf Envisat und jeder bei der ESA ist happy, dass es ihn gab. Und im Grunde genommen war es so ein Elternteil für die ganzen wissenschaftlichen Nachfolgesatelliten, die da kommen. Und jetzt hoffen wir halt, dass wir weiterhin Glück haben. Und wenn wir die Sentinels gut in den Orbit bekommen und die gut funktionieren, woran ich keinen Grund zum Zweifel habe, wären wir, was Envisat uns als Legacy mitgegeben hat, wirklich fortsetzen können. Nein, ich glaube, wir haben damit so ein bisschen das Bild vom Envisat gezeichnet. Ich hätte gern noch mehr Anekdoten erzählt, von denen es ja wirklich sehr, sehr viele gab.
Ja, dann machen wir trotzdem mal hier einen Punkt. Vielen Dank, Michael, wie schon angedeutet, zu den GMS Nachfolgesystemen, wenn wir hier in Kürze auch noch ein weiteres Gespräch nachliefern. Trotz alledem vielen Dank für den Überblick.
Dank dir herzlich. Habt ihr Erinnerungen zurückgebracht?
Ja, schwelgend. Ja, und auch wie immer, danke fürs Zuhören. Das war's, Raumzeit, die 41. Ich sag Tschüss und bis bald.